[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis einen schönen guten
abend und willkommen zu knapp 20 minuten
nachrichten mit einem wirklich
unglaublichen fußball finale mit katja
stresow fußball deutschland blickt heute
noch sevilla guten abend und diesen
wichtigen themen des tages
energiequelle wenn die eu will die
windräder vor europas küsten in den
nächsten jahrzehnten um das zwanzigfache
ausbauen
reizthema altkanzler die ampelkoalition
streicht gerhard schröder als konsequenz
aus seiner lobbyarbeit das büro und
andere privilegien
fan invasion in andalusien vor dem
europapokal-finale zwischen frankfurt
und glasgow ist sie via fest in
hessischer und schottischer hand
wie unabhängig von russischem gas und öl
werden das ist ja eine der großen fragen
seit russlands einmarsch in die ukraine
um putins kriegskasse nicht noch weiter
zu füllen die eu will nun mit 300
milliarden euro den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien fördern über
windenergie beraten heute die
regierungschefinnen chefs aus
deutschland dänemark belgien und den
niederlanden mit dabei auch die eu
kommissionspräsident in beim nordsee
gipfel im dänischen esbjerg in dänemark
gilt beim thema windenergie als
vorzeigebeispiel das kleine land
zwischen ost- und nordsee lag schon
jetzt fast die hälfte seines
strombedarfs mit windkraft in
deutschland sind es etwa 23 prozent in
der gesamten eu nur 14 und das soll sich
jetzt ändern die eu plant die
kapazitäten ihrer offshore windparks bis
2050 zu verzwanzigfachen anne gellinek
berichtet
es ist natürlich kein zufall dass
ausgerechnet heute die dänische
regierung zum sogenannten wind gipfel an
die nordseeküste lädt zu gast der
deutsche kanzler und
eu-kommissionspräsident in von der leyen
windparks sind ein wichtiger teil der
lösung für europas energieproblem das
sich seit russlands überfall auf die
ukraine noch verschärft hat klar ist
dass wir die abhängigkeit von russland
beenden müssen so schnell wie möglich
und sehr viel schneller als wir vor dem
krieg gedacht hatten den weg zu einer
solchen unabhängigkeit sieht die
eu-kommission im turbo aus bau von
erneuerbaren energien bis 2030 sollen
sie im europäischen energiemix nicht
mehr 40 sondern 45 prozent ausmachen
dazu sollen die genehmigungsverfahren
deutlich erleichtert werden noch immer
dauert es in der eu fast neun jahre bis
ein windrad strom liefert auch der
ausbau von solardächern soll schneller
vorankommen so sollen sie auf
öffentlichen neubauten ab 2026 pflicht
werden auf privathäusern ab 2029 die
industrie begrüßt die pläne im prinzip
fragt sich aber ob sie realistisch sind
es ist leider so häufig so in
europäischen politik ansetzen das
zunächst mal ziele erhöht werden aber
die antworten wie das dann gehen soll
die richtige umsetzung wie muss der
rahmen aussehen dass dem das passiert
das ist einfach sehr sehr sprach für die
versorgung mit flüssiggas und
wasserstoff schlägt die eu kommission
einer art einkaufsgemeinschaft vor damit
sich die europäer nicht gegenseitig
konkurrenz machen der umbau der
energiewirtschaft wird so rechnet die
kommission rund 300 milliarden euro
kosten geld das aus dem eu-haushalt und
dem emissionshandel kommen soll zuerst
aber müssen die eu mitgliedstaaten und
das europaparlament den plänen zustimmen
europa plant also die zukunft der
energieversorgung weg von russischer
energie aber wie dazu finden sie viele
weitere informationen und ein interview
mit wirtschaftsminister habeck online
und in der zdf- heute
blicken wir in die ukraine aus dem
belagerten asaf stahlwerk in mariupol
sollen sich hunderte weitere ukrainische
kämpfer ergeben haben heißt es nach
russischen angaben
was passiert mit ihnen wir sprechen
gleich darüber mit unserem reporter in
der ukraine
vorher aber thomas garcia über tag 84
des krieges er beginnt sein berichtet
mario pahl
kämpfer des asa frequenz hinter ihnen
das stahlwerk und die zeit in wessen
kellern wochen vor ihnen eine zeit in
russischer kriegsgefangenschaft eine
zeit der angst wohl denn ihr schicksal
ist ungewiss
als helden gelten sie in der ukraine
einer von ihnen ist daria zog ohno was
freund sie in sicherheit aber in sorge
es spielt keine rolle wie stolz ich auf
ihn bin sagt sie wenn er doch wohl
weiter in lebensgefahr ist die
gefangenen es sind männer und frauen und
so sagt russland nun knapp 700 weitere
die aufgegeben hätten
in mariupol haben sich weitere
nationalisten ergeben seit montag sagt
er weiter fast 1000 gefangene davon 80
verwundete kiew bestätigt diese zahlen
nicht sieht keine kapitulation es sei
eine koordinierte rettungsaktion die
evakuierungs mission geht weiter sie
wird von unserem militär und vom
geheimdienst überwacht die
einflussreichsten internationalen
vermittler sind beteiligt ziel ein
gefangenenaustausch moskau weigert sich
konfrontation weiter auch mit
waffengewalt im don bosco lido geriet
eine fabrik des deutschen gipsplatten
herstellers knauf unter beschuss das
werk seit kriegsbeginn menschenleer wer
es attackierte unklar
ganz im westen ebenfalls luftangriffe
nach lemberg bürgermeister sagt moskau
wolle so dort gebündelte
hilfsorganisationen verunsichern
mögliche kriegsverbrechen in kiew ging
es darum heute erstmals vor gericht
dieser 21 jährige russe soll im
nordosten sowie an den ukrainischen
zivilisten erschossen haben er bekannte
sich schuldig ist droht lebenslange haft
immerhin er weiß was ihn erwarten könnte
dias auf kämpfer in den händen der
russen sie nicht
mehr in der ukraine in einem vorort von
kiew ist für uns johannes hano johannes
fast 1000 kämpfer auf dem stahlwerk
sollen jetzt also in russischer
gefangenschaft sein was könnte denn mit
ihnen passieren
also das liegt jetzt ganze den händen
von vladimir putin nur von der sich den
größten propaganda erfolg verspricht er
wollte ja immer möglichst einige
zumindest dieser kämpfer gefangen nehmen
um sie vor gericht stellen zu können um
zu beweisen ist es sich bei ihnen genau
um die nazis handelt von denen er die
ukraine befreien will und jetzt ist die
frage wofür sie angeklagt werden könnten
und vor allen dingen wo sie angeklagt
werden könnten die dumme hat ja ein
gesetz auf den weg gebracht dass diese
einheiten als terrororganisation
einstuft dafür könnten sie jetzt
verurteilt werden ohne dass man ihnen
kriegsverbrechen nachweisen muss und
dann ist die frage wo sie verurteilt
werden obwohl sie vor gericht gestellt
werden findet dass in russland statt
droht ihnen lebenslange haft in einem
lager werden sie in donetsk oder lohans
diesen russischen satellit republiken
vor gericht gestellt droht ihnen der tod
durch erschießen anders als in russland
geht dort nach wie vor die todesstrafe
und das wäre natürlich das tragische
ende dieser kapitulation muss man schon
sagen der russische der ukrainische
präsident hat seine truppen angewiesen
sich zu ergeben um den sicheren tod in
diesem stahlwerk zu verhindern also das
wäre sicherlich das tragische ergebnis
wenn sie dann vor gericht gestellt
werden und möglicherweise erschossen
werden aus der ukraine johannes hano
dankeschön
die bedrohung durch russland hat
finnland und schweden dazu gebracht ihre
jahrzehntelange neutralität aufzugeben
heute beantragen beide länder offiziell
den beitritt zur nato ihre botschafter
überreichten nato-generalsekretär
stoltenberg die entsprechenden dokumente
eigentlich wollten die nato staaten
unmittelbar mit dem beitrittsgesprächen
beginnen aber der türkische präsident
erdogan hat das erst mal blockiert auf
einer parteiveranstaltung verlangt er
von schweden und finnland zunächst
mehrere kunden auszuliefern die für ihn
terroristen sind
die türkei scheint die drohung jetzt
also wirklich wahr zu machen florian
hahn gut kommt dass bei der nato sicher
nicht an oder
definitiv nicht das hat die feierliche
stimmung von heute früh als diese
anträge eingereicht wurden erstmal
zunichte gemacht einerseits sagen viele
musste man mit diesem schritt nach den
harten worten der letzten tage aus
ankara durchaus rechnen andererseits
zeigt diese blockade von heute eben den
alliierten dass erdogan jetzt wirklich
aufs ganze geht mir ganz hohem einsatz
pokert und auch auf das risiko hin
dass er die wichtigsten alliierten des
westens damit verprellt in kreisen der
nato setzt man jetzt völlig auf die
krisendiplomatie die derzeit in vollem
gange ist heute noch wird sich der us
aussenminister anthony blinken in new
york mit seinem türkischen kollegen zu
treffen und darüber beraten und noch
geben sich die diplomaten mit denen ich
hier vorher reden konnte überzeugt dass
man die türkei noch ins boot holen kann
man muss sagen alles andere das wäre für
die nato auch nichts weniger als eine
katastrophe
das würde eben das scheitern in der
einheit bedeuten die die nato in den
letzten wochen so ausgezeichnet hat und
das wiederum das wäre ein signal des
sieges vor allem für einen menschen
nämlich den russischen präsidenten
wladimir putin danke für diese
einschätzung florian mayer
durch den krieg in der ukraine drohen
vor allem in ärmeren ländern massive
hungersnöte was kann man dagegen tun
beim treffen der entwicklungsministerium
minister der g7 staaten in berlin hat
die deutsche ministerin schulze ein
globales bündnis vorgeschlagen das solle
schnelle hilfe koordinieren die
landwirtschaft müsse auch wegen der
klimakrise widerstandsfähiger gemacht
werden
altkanzler schröder und seine kontakte
zu russlands präsident putin
umstritten sind die ja schon länger
jetzt könnten sie zumindest indirekt
folgen haben als
bundeskanzler führte schröder von 1998
bis 2005 eine rot grüne koalition und
konnte schon damals gut mit dem
russischen präsidenten
danach übernahm er aufgaben unter
anderem bei nord stream der russischen
gazprom und beim energiekonzern rosneft
aus dem ukraine krieg zog schröder keine
konsequenzen nun soll er wesentliche
privilegien eines altkanzlers verlieren
lasst bohnsack und andré schubert
so sah man ihn häufig in den letzten
jahren als lobbyist russische
energiekonzerne selten bis gar nicht war
gerhard schröder als altkanzler für
deutschland unterwegs das wird ihn nun
privilegien wie büros und mitarbeiter
kosten wir sagen jetzt man kriegt die
amds ausstattung so lange wie man auch
eine fortwährende verpflichtung erfüllt
tut man das nicht nicht bekommt man
keine angst ausstattung über 400.000
euro jährlich kostet das büro des ex
kanzlers den staat auf schröders
russland kontakte und der ukraine krieg
gehen die haushaltspolitiker bewusst
nicht ein das ist dann keine lex
schröder sondern die geht eben für alle
ex kanzlerin und ex kanzler und da sind
wir haushälter dann diejenigen die sich
um der steuerzahler geld kümmern uns
sagen wo darf es ausgegeben werden und
wo nicht die union wollte eigentlich
noch weiter gehen und auch das
ruhegehalt schröders streichen jetzt
schließt man sich dem antrag der ampel
an wir haben die sondersituation weil er
hat schröder dass er sich dezidiert
gegen die interessen unseres landes
richtet und das muss konsequenzen haben
er hat damit jeden rechtlichen und vor
allen dingen auch moralischen anspruch
verwirkt den linken wiederum geht es
nicht allein um schröder auch ex
kanzlerin angela merkel bräuchte nicht
die ihr genehmigt neun mitarbeiter mit
den dazugehörigen büros ehemalige
bundeskanzler brauchen kein hofstaat
nach ihrer kanzlerschaft man kann hier
im bundestag dafür sorgen dass termine
die sie für die allgemeinheit wahrnehmen
organisiert werden aber das ist
ausgeufert und das sollte beendet werden
seine reputation hat er putin freund
schröder spätestens mit kriegsbeginn
verloren jetzt sind auch seine
altkanzler privilegien weg
es ist eine lehre aus der korona
pandemie das bundeskabinett hat heute
einen notfall mechanismus für bafög
beschlossen um studierende in
krisensituationen unterstützen zu können
der bafög höchstsatz liegt ab herbst bei
809 euro im monat das sollen etwa die
durchschnittlichen lebenshaltungskosten
von studierenden abbilden aber vor allem
in westdeutschen großstädten reicht das
nicht im schnitt kosten wg-zimmer 414
euro monate in münchen dem spitzenreiter
sogar 680 euro und lag nicht alle
bekommen bafög von knapp 3 millionen
studierenden sind etwa
466.000 bafög berechtigt wer stattdessen
kellner oder einen anderen studierenden
jobs arbeitet hatte es wären corona
schwer romanesco
wallone großer studiert in hamburg
engagiert sich im freien zusammenschluss
der studentinnenschaften sie kennt die
nöte von kommilitonen
existenzängste durch jobverlust in der
pandemie oder bafög probleme 300 euro
bekam sie während ihres bachelorstudiums
das leben kann man sich damit natürlich
absolut nicht finanzieren ich habe dann
meine eltern das kindergeld dazu
bekommen und habe eben immer nebenbei
gearbeitet mit dem geld was mir zur
verfügung stand lag ich auf jeden fall
den ersten semestern unterhalb der
armutsgrenze nach einer analyse des
paritätischen wohlfahrtsverbandes sind
30 prozent der studierenden in
deutschland aktuell von armut betroffen
ihr mittleres einkommen liege bei 802
euro gleichzeitig erhielten immer
weniger bafög die tatsache dass nur elf
prozent der studierenden überhaupt bafög
beziehen wir haben eine 30-prozentige
armutsquote haben zeigt dass sie etwas
fundamental schiefläuft wir müssen eine
bafög-reform schaffen die das passt
wirklich armutsfest macht die
bundesregierung hat mittlerweile pläne
für eine bafög reform vorgelegt heute
thema im bildungsausschuss
so sollen etwa die bedarfssätze um fünf
prozent steigen dazu der wohnkosten
zuschlag um elf prozent auf 360 euro als
konsequenz aus der pandemie so ganz
aktuell noch ein dauerhafter
notfallmechanismus hinzu kommen der in
krisenzeiten gilt das haben jetzt auch
studierende anspruch auf bafög die
vorher nicht da runter gefallen sind zum
beispiel weil die einkommensgrenze bei
den eltern überschritten würde oder
fräulein fachrichtungswechsel vorlag für
lohne grote und ihre mitstreiter das
alles nur ein erster schritt und die
armut unter studierenden zu bekämpfen
müsse deutlich mehr passieren
der flugzeugabsturz in china im
vergangenen märz ist möglicherweise
absichtlich verursacht worden das meldet
das wall street journal und verweist
dabei auf daten des flugschreibers die
auch von us ermittlern ausgewertet
wurden und so zitiert die zeitung eine
quelle aus ermittlerkreisen
das flugzeug habe das geht was ihn von
jemandem im cockpit befohlen wurde
wahrscheinlich handle es sich dabei um
einen der beiden piloten die maschine
hatte auf einem inlandsflug plötzlich
massiv an höhe verloren und war dann
fast senkrecht auf dem boden
aufgeschlagen alle 132 menschen an bord
kamen ums leben
ein neuer klima- bericht zeigt einmal
mehr wie sehr die zeit direkt vier
indikatoren beobachtet die
weltwetterorganisation und alle sind im
roten bereich die konzentration von
treibhausgasen in der atmosphäre lag
schon 2020 um 149 prozent über dem
vorindustriellen niveau der
meeresspiegel steigt inzwischen um
viereinhalb millimeter pro jahr doppelt
so stark wie noch vor einigen jahren
außerdem wird das wasser der ozeane jahr
für jahr wärmer und saurer kann daher
immer weniger zusätzliches co2 binden
jetzt kommt zum fußball denn in weniger
als zwei stunden steigt das spiel der
spiele
frankfurt genau so sieht's aus es ist
das finale in der europa league gegen
die glasgow rangers im heißen spanischen
sevilla es geht um den titel natürlich
einen platz in der kommenden
champions-league-saison und um die
erfüllung eines ganz großen traum ist
zwei fan-gruppen ein gedanke ein
internationaler titel soll nach
jahrzehnten wieder mal geholt werden
entweder von den blauen aus glasgow oder
den weißen aus frankfurt ein einmaliges
gefühl hier zu sein das wird die ein tag
der den nächsten jahrzehnt nicht nochmal
schaffen auch wenn ich mir wünschen
würde ja aber da muss man einfach dabei
sein das ist unser gott unser noch
gehört er niemandem aber auch dass
eintrags team ist bester laune es
herrscht siegesgewisse euphorie von den
fans gefeiert
es gibt ja immer so
nicht messbare faktoren und ich denke
diese unterstützung ist ein jahr und das
hilft halt dann meine spiele zu gewinnen
150.000 anhänger aus beiden lagern
sollen in der stadt seien 44.000 finden
im stadion
es wird gedränge geben in den gassen von
silvia
ja nicht nur vor ort in sevilla fiebern
zehntausende eintrat fans dem spiel
entgegen auch in frankfurt unter anderem
im und rund ums stadion werden 60.000
zum public viewing erwartet einige davon
machen sich von der innenstadt dem
frankfurter römer aus auf den weg in
richtung stadion die stimmung jetzt
schon euphorisch ja und in silvia ist
meine kollegin claudia neumann claudia
man hört von 50.000 eintracht-fans und
100000 schottischen anhängern wie
erlebst du die stimmung vor ort
ja heiß im doppelten wortsinn
mittlerweile steigt die anspannung
spürbar die fans beider lager sind so
mittlerweile in so abgesperrte korridore
geleitet worden um sich aufeinander zu
treffen es ist ein besonderes finale die
frankfurter eintracht hat mit den tollen
auftritten in der europa league
tatsächlich auch zum image gewinn des
gesamt- deutschen fußballs wieder
beigetragen angesichts des
enttäuschenden abschneidens in dieser
saison der deutschen vereine in der
champions league und was auch nicht zu
verachten ist auch die rückgewinnung des
images was die fans außerhalb der
fanszenen betrifft da ist durch solche
spiele der punkte wieder ein bisschen
übergesprungen das war ja in der korona
zeit durch verschiedene gründe so ein
bisschen abhandengekommen also dieses
spiel ist wirklich ein besonderes und
kann den funken auch wieder ingesamt
fußball-deutschland überspringen lassen
ein besonderes vidal 21 uhr geht's los
danke claudia ja nach deutschland um den
verbleib bzw den wiederaufstieg in die
fußball bundesliga geht es dann morgen
abend im ersten von zwei
relegationsspielen zwischen hertha bsc
und dem hamburger sv
in der medaillenschmiede team bereitet
sich die hertha auf die relegation vor
besonders im fokus felix magath es geht
gegen seinen herzensverein bei dem er
spieler und trainer war die quatsch
zu sagen
dass jetzt der hsv der gegner ist ist
mir völlig egal stimmt natürlich nicht
aber er spielt aber keine rolle
während herta zuletzt drei matchbälle
für den klassenerhalt vergeben hat trotz
der hsv mit trainer timm walter vor
selbstvertrauen nur durch fünf siege in
folge haben die hamburger ihre
aufstiegschance erhalten
das haben wie gesagt erst morgen ein
geschenk hat ja heute ist's ja mittwoch
das heißt die lottozahlen wurden gezogen
die gewinnzahlen lauten 18 25 41 43 45
die superzahl ist die sechs weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 5 157
morgen ziehen von westen heftige
gewitter auf auch am freitag drohen
unwetter alles wichtige dazu erfahren
sie gleich von katja horneffer christian
sievers hat um 21.45 das heute-journal
für sie und morgen begrüßt sie hier an
dieser stelle mitri sirin ich
verabschiede mich machen wir es gut
[Musik]
guten abend heute war noch mal ein tag
zum durchschnaufen das wird sich jetzt
aber ändern denn von südwesten wird es
immer gewittriger dass es schwül warme
luft die dazu uns kommt heute nacht
merken wir davon noch nichts aber es ist
schon sehr warm in den großen städten
des ruhrgebietes sinken die temperaturen
nicht unter 20 grad deutlich angenehmer
sind die nachttemperaturen in bayern mit
10 bis 8 grad und morgen wird es
schweißtreibend zumeist mit temperaturen
von 26 bis 31 grad und nur der nordsee
ist das etwas kinder schon morgen
vormittag kann es das erste gewitter im
emsland geben sonst aber gibt es noch
viel sonnenschein aber die luft ist
amtlich und spätestens in den
nachmittagsstunden geht es dann los mit
kräftigen gewittern hier im saarland in
rheinland pfalz nordrhein westfalen auch
im westlichen niedersachsen und zum
abend dann auch aus dem schwarzwald
heraus und aus den alpen wir sprechen
von unwetter mit sturmböen bis 100
kilometer pro stunde mit starkregen bis
40 liter pro quadratmeter in kurzer zeit
und von hagelkörnern mit einer
durchschnittsgröße von drei zentimetern
in der nacht zum freitag ziehen die
gewitter durch dann kommen die nächsten
kräftigen gewitter hier in der mitte an
und erst zum wochenende beruhigt sich
gelagert genannt